star wars the bad batch episode 12
john take it away rescue on ryloth get
ready to join us for the reaction
highlights for the bad batch very much
enjoying this show if you want to come
watch the full thing with us that's over
at our patreon where we have also a
bunch of other shows where at the same
tier
you get the reaction highlights and the
full-length watch along if you want to
sync up with your own copy
huge thank you to prothom jindal for
assembling these highlights which you're
about to see on the youtubes
don't forget to leave a like on this
video if you like us you like star wars
you like prothom
that's the best reason to leave a like
let's hop into this let's do it
[Music]
jam syndulla the liberator of ryloth
now the traitor of ryloth you're the
traitor of the galaxy
your loyal followers will be even easier
to deal with your daughter too
oh here inhabit it tell us where she is
and i will ensure she has returned to
you safely
i have seen how you treat your allies
admiral
i prefer to be your enemy
have it your way king
scour the entire planet if you have to i
want all of syndulla's sympathizers
found and arrested
sir oh people are not insurgents
we have no cause to arrest them
syndulla's forces attacked our transport
and shots on a tatar
i was there that blast didn't come from
cham
or his fighters then please enlighten me
who is responsible i
don't know sir leave the thinking to me
captain
you have your orders okay hey just cause
he's a clone he can think okay
it's only a matter of time before she's
found oh no crosshair is probably going
after her
probably the squad responsible for that
shot
some of that help a chopper drop back
i'm here hang on we searched the house
the syndulla girl's gone she could have
already fled the planet
not without her parents find her
new plan chop meet me at the base we
need to send out the transmission
and fast
oh this is when the bad batch gets
involved we are receiving a recorded
transmission
patch it through omega
you have to come back to rylan help me
obi-wan kadopi
era the empire's taken my parents and
they are after email too
sorry i need your help you gave her
a calm channel for emergencies and that
sounded pretty urgent
we have to go children often overreact
no we don't she needs us
omega it's a big galaxy
we can't put ourselves on the line every
time someone's in trouble
why not isn't that what soldiers do
[Music]
she's right no i'm going against my
whole identity
that's right we're soldiers oh damn
care to tell us why the empire is after
you because my father is charm syndulla
the freedom fighter the empire's begun
targeting anyone loyal to him
what do you want us to do free my
parents from the capital
i don't have anyone else to ask
do it citizens of ryloth
the shocking attack on your beloved
senator has left you shaken
hunter cross hairs here
great just what we need
[Music]
we're killing cross hairs right now like
how they're all kind of afraid of him
rhilo's not a separatist planet exactly
[Music]
wait here always hunting
how the hell did you get so high up
there so fast man
hunting the empire will know we're here
and so will crosshair command received a
transmission from a probe droid in
sector 5.
the show has great music yeah i just
want my parents back
you will care eventually
hey they fly now
the element of surprise is gone there's
nothing we can do
wait you can't leave i'll pay you double
what you're asking us to do it's not
worth the risk
not to you
what the [ __ ] what it's all i can hear
when he makes noise now
she's trying to save her family hunter
i'd do the same for you
that same look i knew it damn i learned
so much from this
girl it's his epiphany face
clone force 99 is on ryloth
we have a battalion of troopers right
outside that's not enough
i know what they're capable of i suggest
you stay on task
or i will find someone who can
you look at
attention in the empire why do you trust
him so much
because he's my brother you can trust
them too
all we need to do is think of a plan and
convince hunter
and all my brothers are down there on
your planet too
so this is the side you've chosen you
both attacked an imperial convoy
what did you think would happen that
gave us no choice
we had to protect hera
that's what i'm trying to do admiral
rampart squad is out there
looking for her so please if you know
where she
is tell me i'll protect her we trusted
you hauser
i won't make that mistake again damn it
earn that respect house i've seen the
hauser since he's all right man
the chance he's questioning the orders
i attacked the capitol what that was my
plan
not the capital yeah the imperial
refinery riot the capitals
[Laughter]
where is the control console right
inside the main gate
it is heavily guarded but chopper can
slip inside with the other droids
and disable the cannons all right you
two go with chopper as backup
but at a distance really
even omegas like really all right
echo and i will scale the capital wall
and free harris parents
i guess we'll follow your lead
they're approaching the checkpoint get
ready job
oh man this is choppers episode come on
buddy
dude the droids of the galaxy proud what
do you mean it won't work you said you
could disable the cannons
we have to help chopper
offline you said you wanted to be a
pilot right yeah
well come on
[Music]
that is so loud yeah
a little help
[Music]
nice
and then she killed thousands of
innocent twilights
way to go you two
they're just fighting for a good cause
right now absolutely they're doing some
altruistic
the refinery is under attack i'll handle
it stay here and guard the capital
stay here in my control room
what are you doing here breaking you out
they are mercenaries
but i didn't hire them for this heritage
where is she is she safe
we are getting the hang of this
yes your dangerous and uncontrolled
maneuvering is as confusing to them as
it is to us
fit right in with the team stop
the admiral said to protect the refinery
that's not their
target damn you crosshair
[Music]
oh come on hauser
step up how soon
[Music]
there's a squad out there waiting
one big sheet of metal i'm sorry general
i should have stopped this sooner you
can't stay here they'll know you helped
us
i will not abandon my squad they're good
men
i have to try to get through them go
well there's still time could be a
little rough good luck bud
what's so what's going on his chip yeah
i don't know maybe he just got a bad
ship too
high five this is their way
out
[Music]
brothers we came here to free ryloth
from separatist control
and we succeeded we're now being ordered
to target the very people we swore to
protect
and i will not be a part of it any
longer
how's it who will stand with me
whoa whoa
whoa arrest those cheaters
huh
oh i really like that yeah the shot they
had the
you see across her guys in the dark
looking up and they cut to the guy who's
entering the light
that's cool visual storytelling that's
beautiful guys
i only like it because i picked up on it
these occupations are happening on other
planets beside dry love
i hope to have fought my last war but
our people need us now
more than ever we must organize
they seem pretty psyched to fight last
episode i
have my own people to look out for it is
time for us to go
well co-pilot we didn't do too bad
do you have to go oh
but i'm sure i'll see you around and
keep an eye on your brothers
they need it i will
thanks for believing in me no
power friendship
[Music]
it would seem i underestimated your full
friends if only they were fighting for
us
instead of against us request permission
to hunt them down
granted here we go
you're right there yeah i mean
cause now that he's off the leash you
know he's gonna stop at nothing
cool this is a good episode it's a
really good episode i really
i like these tight
tense episodes that they do
and there's so much to appreciate about
it because there's so many different
turns that are happening
like getting hera involved in the mix
here and seeing these early stages
before she becomes like one of the
greatest pilots during the rebellion
is just awesome to see and i think an
unexpected turn that it took
was her connection with omega like i was
so endeared to that
um that by the time they were saying bye
i was like oh man omega just stuck with
these like four older dudes this whole
time she's here and she
she's really got a peer to bond with
another girl
someone who's interested in the same
stuff that she is like damn it man oh
that was that was so
nice and it constantly is just making me
wonder about the future of
omega and the bad batch or i guess you
would just consider omega part of the
bad batch
um but i it makes me constantly wonder
about the future of them like do they
die
uh what becomes of their fate because
they're not in uh
the rebels show so what becomes of them
and they retire they retire yeah i don't
need to get involved in this war anymore
no we're just gonna live on the ship but
they had and like they had so many great
moments here like hauser
kind of confuses me a bit i mean maybe
you guys can clear it up
uh because yes it's it's like
i get is there like a gray area to the
whole
chip thingy you know because order 66
was very specifically fine-tuned you
know to be this like obedient soldier it
seemed like it was mainly to take out
the jedi um
but it's like obviously the argument
that hauser was presenting
was that these are innocent people and
he could logically see how they're
innocent
yes people like crosshair don't seem to
see that
at all yeah whatsoever yeah so does he
have like a weak chip a bad chip
um has it all does it come down to the
chip
yeah because i mean it seems like the
chip is able to like you know make you
act on an entirely worked out paradigm
that's just been implanted into you so i
can't
yeah like it seems like it would be
directly designed to be prohibitive
of you coming to your own conclusions
and acting on them but at the same time
i don't know i mean maybe it's
i could see it being the kind of thing
hinging on what he says literally which
is
these were we were fighting to liberate
these people from one group and now
we're just imprisoning them in a
different way yeah and so yeah
just i guess the one earmark of that
that makes me wonder is like yeah maybe
if
they're just asking you to act on such
clearly false information that like you
just can't
i don't know like it yeah i didn't quite
get it but
in terms of i'm sure you guys can clear
it up perhaps
in the comments um but i did really
i did really like the moment where he
does uh talk to
the soldier the other troopers gets
through to them they're all like
yeah you're right you know why don't you
think about that yeah
it's weird i just never crossed my mind
except half of them it did i like that
too
is about half of them uh you know
decided to give up the fight which left
you know the perfect amount to a wrestle
yeah that's true well yeah crosstalk
orders it in but i like
i like how crossover just seems to
progressively have gotten more and more
evil
i feel like the show's trying to sell us
on no he's bad
no he's evil but i think there'll still
be a turn yeah
what i mean there's got to be something
left of their relationship
i really feel like the show is just
trying to make us think that there's no
chance
yeah i think it's that's that's what i'm
talking enough to
i don't know i personally would like it
if he is just a bad dude
but i am not thinking that's what's
going to be the case
yeah it's like that i i could i i mean
yeah it's like i could imagine a really
juicy version of this where they do at
least
play on the back and forth and the early
stuff with omega where she's like you
know i can tell you're trying to fight
it just keep on trying to fight it
uh yeah and i could i could see a juicy
version
of that where they bring it back like
maybe he reunites
in the same physical space with the
batch and they have some kind of
maybe way of restraining him and then
trying to almost convince him or even i
don't know if
they have a means of forcibly removing
the chip but like having it be a kind of
battle of ideology as well before yeah
him just
fully choosing the dark side of things
or something because like
as much as it is sinister and nasty to
have the chip and the orders and all
that stuff it could be even more
heart-wrenching if he just comes down on
the side of no given my free will i
still choose this you know
yeah and i kind of i kind of hope he
does do that yeah making it
more interesting and then this tar
has his name general tar grandma emerald
tar
uh uh uh rampart rampart yeah
yeah uh rampart i'm i'm really growing
more interested in this character as
it's progressing i'm finding him to be
uh i mean it's like there's nothing
super unique about his personality
but i will say that
he's got this good guys about himself
because whenever people
whenever these characters in star wars
are in this position i'm like
man you just come across like so evil 24
7. you know
yeah and whenever you're talking about
like oh we're here to protect you guys
as part of our new empire like you
always sound
like there's no even attempt to hide
that sinister
nature where he does a good job at that
yeah
you know he's like that uh corporate guy
in
management who you think is a good
employer but really he's a sneaky
[ __ ]
yeah and he knows what image to to put
out
in order to distract people from yeah
and they gave chopper some
great moments to shine which i really
loved
was to fly and of course yeah with hera
seeing all those awesome moments of her
learning to pilot tech too getting a
chance to do some action scenes too with
a flight i really
i really enjoyed particularly this set
piece for some reason i don't know if
it's like just the
the mood and excitement what i started
feeling
and i think this is what gripped me the
most about it i started feeling like
they're all start before
uh he even hunter even rejects the money
i started really getting the sense like
they think they are starting to care
about something bigger than themselves
and bigger than
money yeah you know what i mean like
they've always had a heart and they've
always cared and they look after each
other you know what i mean
yeah um but it seems like they've kind
of been in this weird wobbly grant which
is understandable because that's kind of
the point of the show is where do we
belong in this world
yeah but like as this you know defected
group this rejects of of clones
where do we belong i guess we just got
to survive because we don't really want
to do what they're doing
and and then here in the action scenes i
started there was like a specific
i got this like image in my head of tech
when he is piloting through he's kind of
grinding his teeth and just getting
really involved in the action
and i started really feeling like oh
they they care they really care and then
when he rejects the money i'm like okay
so yeah i was picking up on that
good because now it's becoming more
interesting to me for them
to see the bad batch involved in the mix
here because it doesn't come down to
money or anything like that or just
being like [ __ ]
omega's hustling my ass you know they're
sneaking up
into trouble they're beginning to become
aligned with
a higher purpose than before and
that's that's why i think i really like
the action it's more of the emotional
context underneath it that made the
action more exciting to see them winning
yeah absolutely and i think it makes for
a nice progression because you know you
have the earlier on dynamic of like oh
they're taking bounties and stuff like
that to
get back situated at least to be able to
move around
freely throughout the galaxy and you
know aspects of that remind you of the
most recently the mandalorian because
he's always taken uh
uh bounties and stuff she's got a kid
but yeah i like
seeing this sort of transition of like
yeah that's a sensible place for them to
use their expertise
but now seeing them get more and more
involved and again
using that transition point of the rise
of the empire now yeah as a means of
getting them to like now i'm envisioning
perhaps a show where they go
from you know a different corner and
quadrant of this intergalactic
conflict to the next and maybe yeah like
throwing their lot in with just all the
underdogs
of the galaxy wherever they happen to be
at the time or something like that yeah
it just seems like there's a lot of good
potential and i like the
i feel like sometimes you know they're
gonna go do the stuff so the debates can
feel
rot or can feel requisite and i i
kind of feel like it's been a natural
build up to this and a natural
confrontation of them being like yeah
what is our place
we don't really have anybody to fight
for now and now it's kind of yeah
a journey of them discovering what that
is now that they do
truly have freedom and autonomy you know
well said it's the first first one today
first first smooth the rattle of the day
this is a good one it's only 9 p.m what
do you know only
getting started boy it's gonna be good
but this is like
so much cool action and great like they
more in the past
couple of episodes especially it seems
like they were just ramping up these
like
gorgeous oh that's just like a sci-fi
concept art piece
come to life in an action scene it's
awesome to look at
you know uh well yeah they always have
this they the
choice of music that they have is is
like this is there's a
terror around the corner that is like
foreboding terror that's
that's slowly creeping up on them like
whenever they cut to
freaking crosshair and that music they
play it's just such like an icky sci-fi
synth tune just just
menace music i love it i love it um yeah
there's a lot of great things to
appreciate about it
so to you 1 000 people who watch this
thank you so much guys what'd you think
about this episode what is
everything that we should have
definitely talked about subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button last but not least patron of the
day
shout out
anissa oliver of all the people here and
now
who we could still you know shout out
this month and i was thinking
like who could be in the bad batch with
omega
and hera you know you seem like you
would be a perfect
intergalactic space pilot you know you
got a spunk
you got the good nature so people would
like underestimate you at first before
you kick an
ass across the galaxy
and then you know prove that you're a
lot stronger than your bubbly demeanor
would imply on the surface you know so
anissa
i miss your face i got a lot of messages
i know i gotta pick up from you but i
hope you're doing well
thanks for staying pledged so long and
we'll catch you next week
hope you're enjoying the bad match hope
you even watch the bad match
love you nissa always i'm warmed up
let's see so let's go
[Music]